okay guys this is going to be the very
last episode I am pretty sure at least I
guess there's not much else to say it's
it feels weird if it's been a fun a
couple of a couple of days but let's
keep playing here it's declared civilian
movement will be strictly country
where's my camera where's my camera this
is going in my cringe compilation
electronic communications are restricted
and I have granted enhanced powers to
our security agencies in addition to
these measures all androids must be
handed over to the authorities
immediately temporary camps are being
set up in all our major cities to
contain and destroy them I am now asking
all civilians to cooperate with the
authorities and rest assured that
everything in our power is being done to
guarantee the security of our nation
well
oh my god this is happening too fast I
have too many thoughts what about the
Jericho
what can you tell us about the assault
that happened last night the FBI raided
an abandoned freighter in Detroit at
10:45 p.m. yesterday several thousand
androids were destroyed or captured our
forces are now combing the streets to
ensure that none got through the net we
are going to find them one by oh my god
Hillary Clinton please please Madam
President is it true that a large number
of deviants are still on the loose we
don't have the full reports at this time
but if so I can assure you they will
soon be apprehended and destroyed please
please is it true that the androids
could hack our IT systems like nuclear
power plants and military bases all
androids working on sensitive sites have
been neutralized and all IT systems
suspended to avoid any risks of hacking
the situation is under control please
please my brain it's like I have too
many thoughts and I don't know what to
keep going and then I'll see if I as the
leader of the deviants been apprehended
the deviant that is known as Marcus has
not been located yet but we will soon
track it down and neutralize it thank
you
that will be all oh my god Jesus Christ
they really hate the deviants don't they
there's not even a single like even the
president is like oh they all need to
die I thought we had the point of this
peaceful revolution was that they could
empathize with us and be like oh they're
not actually violent haven't done
anything actually harmful so there's
really no reason for us to be afraid of
them clearly we're outnumbered so he
makes sense not to go into violence
because we can't win anyway and there's
no one else really to inspire but other
DV and other human isn't going to join a
violent cost for another race or
whatever you want to call it and then
they got Hillary Clinton on top of all
of it because I know they don't want to
show Trump because probably they think
is evil or whatever whatever your
opinion on Trump is but here they just
make Hillary look evil so what is
happening that was really confusing and
it's also like wait did everything we
did just not matter there I thought we
changed the public's opinion by making
these choices
everyone got so mad at me for picking
that peaceful option connor model 3 1 3
2 4 8 connor model i'm expected hey when
really it made the most sense like i
stick with the decision okay that's
pretty cool
Alexa that's pretty cool
Alexa played Esposito
Alexa
[Music]
piece of [ __ ]
Alexa played Esposito right now oh my
follow me will escort you thanks alright
I guess where to go
we're not to worry about AI any time
soon but I have my orders
[Music]
cyber life upside down leads sit cabe
but tight anymore you know
all right so we'll see how Connor they
don't know that he's a deviant yet so
we'll see how Connor reacts to I thought
his involvement on Jericho was pretty
lame so maybe we'll see something cool
him doing now I hope so that is a big
statue well this looks like the whole in
episode what is it - with the Emperor
the attack of me have let me disfigured
and before we have neutralized all the
deviants in high important positions
also here's a buncha deviants for no
good reason at all 54 I also find a lot
of interesting comments from you guys
really seeing not empathizing with the
deviants as if like if it was real life
you'd be freaking out if they started a
revolution
pre construct pretty fast right so we
could take this guy out by hugging him
we can hug him out like hey what's up or
we can kick him in the knee
I like the knee kick idea that's always
a good no okay well let's not do the
knee kick then I like this Alexa I liked
it
shoot him in the head no we get shot in
the head
well what I was gonna say before a lot
of people I think we look at species and
we look at humans like where somehow the
end all and the greatest or whatever and
that's somehow our emotions are more
real than simulated Android when it's
really not that complicated
we're not that special as we like to
think we are and that's why when I said
I don't really mind I said I think it's
natural that if androids take over
that's not really what I meant I just
made more like it's Connor agent 54
levels sub 49 I didn't mean to click I
was thinking hunt agent 54 14 oh hey
look at that
what was this talking about
the last bus leaves in 20 minutes that
doesn't give us much time we've got to
move fast hey we're a family now how
great 20 minutes this is how a chat then
[Music]
no you're not
you'll feel better now
so that's how that's what justified it
oh my gosh she's so creepy she says
thanks Jesus so much
[Music]
do you think she's actually not feeling
cold
[Music]
any less than you are feeling cold
what's the difference between the
simulation of it
heavy rain there was a reference there
in the back of the cinema that's funny
they were playing their games
[Music]
where are we gonna do
we have to keep going everyone catch
that bus
[Music]
stay close to me
we're going to sneak past them without
being noticed go to make it Alice I
promise you they really picked the worst
time ever to try and escape the border
it's like everybody's looking at random
[Music]
Alexa let's go let's frickin do this
alright every soldier in this game is
apparently blind so we should be fine we
gotta save them a man shut the [ __ ] up
yeah
the only good thing you've ever said
Alice Carol you're on my hate list save
Luther how dare you okay
hey buddy
I'm human I just want to go home
my wife is expecting me no please
Alexa that was that thing oh I'm
supposed to do that okay okay
however onion potato can you be if
someone is like no please and they still
shoot him like chief says I just don't
see that happening I but it's happened
many time in history yeah but this is a
modern society isn't it cars you saved
us are you we don't know how to thank
you oh my god it's him
thank you go away no one asks for your
opinion
oh maybe now isn't his time guys but
they call me along the way
don't touch me exactly thank you you
know what they make a good team I got a
burger zone burger time here time I love
oh oh he actually didn't see me what
just happened
what's happening
[Music]
might be running you're a certain sense
of the Felix if you were in that
position you didn't know what to do good
thing it's a video game
bazinga let's go they saw me is that
like a game over or I actually coming to
you
okay alright ever I know everyone's
gonna get pissed at me here cuz I failed
don't worry I'm going to replay at the
end of the episode the outcome but I do
think by failing we get a way more
interesting playthrough so keep watching
all right and at the end I will replay a
couple options that I weren't happy with
okay I couldn't do it right away
I'm sorry Hall Marcus is at the head of
the March come on Hillary
something's happening in Detroit madam
president
oh yeah this is our last effort our last
hope
let's see if this goes anywhere I doubt
it but you know this is the path we
chose or I chose for us
[Music]
at least you're probably getting a
different ending than you seen anyone
else on YouTube I'm just assuming no
one's dumb as me
and you know if anything we make it easy
for them is that a news helicopter or a
drone
I feel like we tried this and it didn't
really work you know open fire and they
all died the end here we are
or maybe Hillary Clinton will fly in and
safe today
this is it guys this is our final Spain
we'll use north as shield
so the media is there to report on
what's gonna happen we don't want
confrontation we are protesting
peacefully
there's no turning back now Oh
we ask that you release all androids
detained in camps and cease all
aggression against us
we are peaceful yes not resort to
violence but we are not leaving until
our people are free
Trump is gonna come in naked save the
day
I believe the androids can be used quite
efficiently in fact I like the Markus
when I won with a - what's happening oh
I can move okay not Simon
don't shoot Simon you can shoot Norah
but not Simon
I don't know
it's dirty fire and unarmed protesters
I kind of wonder anything
[Music]
Oh
yes Michel we are less than a hundred
meters away and events are unfolding as
we speak we will continue to bring you
live updates just Douglas channel 16
Michel back to you hold out as long as
we can
it's Connor time my favorite time it's
done at 10:00 Oh like oh oh oh
X Circle
oh I like this yeah
come on the MSU's when we can't fight
car is like never mind we can convert
them how do this is water it's a lot of
this is the arm with that we need it
we're not outnumbered where do I go
so as long as your deviant you can
convert out of this hang step back
Connor wait no I'm Connor Connor hey
bastard you're spittin image
No
are you kidding me oh yeah great
we got calling
that's another thing everyone's gonna
get pissed at me for I wasn't really
fully paying attention I agree but hey
look it gets more interesting this way
we both have to be strong
they're going to the cans No
now
moving what are you doing
[Music]
get out of there right now she's spying
on your heads
we get the bad ending with car huh
from one tiny mistake
great
for work
I'm scared I don't want to go there's no
choice Berg oh my god don't run you just
have to go through the gate there's
nothing to be scared of they'll be right
behind you
I heard mrs. side wait just give her a
minute
she's just sorry I'm sorry
[Music]
come on it's your turn
deactivate your skin hurry up
[Music]
please God don't
after you
mess
gone
strip off put your clothes in the
dumpster
[Music]
come on this way get a move on
you take this would have a dump no no
please I thank you I gave you an order
oh babe I'll do it don't leave we'll be
right back
throw it over there move it
[Music]
Wow
we can't lean out
no way we can well now we know what's
gonna happen
Eilis get out I was with we're together
what's behind these doors
kara oh my god kara of course Kara got
captured too
that's really just too bad really too
bad have you seen the little girl who
was with me obviously the little girl is
a prisoner here just like Ralph but that
doesn't want to die no Raph doesn't want
to die doesn't about here beep listen
Ralph Nozomi yes it would be difficult
the weapons were armed presents
get a few humans but have you seen it
hold it
Ralph doesn't want to die crap us to
leave right now it's not deleted I got
that to be dumped in the week
what's behind these
[Music]
- to all that remain silent must be
played out
why did I get shot
are you kidding me we're gonna stick
around
Ollis know where you just don't have
time
what's behind these doors pretty cute
Jerry Cara
so they captured you too they came to
take out the Jerry's
they separated us but it's all gonna
work out isn't it
do you know where alice's
a little
we know you yes we think we saw her
Carl if we can help in any way just ask
we have to save the little one
cherry
Jerry
Cara cherry I have to find Alice do you
know where she is
you stay here we come back soon
car are you okay are you hurt
I don't like this place you have to get
out of here come on move along
come on this is so darn well let was now
go
I thought I never see you again
was Alice
you you and you over this way thank you
come on get a move on
go on faster
she says
it's the bad ending but
[Music]
we've got to finish the barricade come
on help me
ddungi me
they help me
the three stooges out again
things are pretty bad things are pretty
bad good dad definitely be better
definitely not the best time to do oh no
that's not gonna stop them
hey hey thank you yes Coco buys us some
time I know it was not an easy decision
to make
I'm sure we're doing the right thing
cool Johnson thank you got my tea
or your people
many of our people have fallen
the humans have no pity for those
different
not sure why I did that
it's time to knowing
it's all hold on for long but I guess
it's better than nothing
they're slaughtering us on the other
side of that barbed wire
nothing we can do about it
how many more of us have to die
is there any Cosworth giving your life
for your the hope of our people I trust
you
we all trust you how is Mark if he's
really not you know what never no matter
what happens now we're making history
oh really not now please
and then she comes back alright alright
alright
Marcus we found what you asked for you
found that despedido remix there's some
journalists over there we have to make
sure they know what's going on
let our people go
okay
he's got real real real fast
Marcus Marcus come look
yes
come to talk to Marcus
come on you have my word they won't try
anything
don't go it's a trap they want to get
you out of the open
don't go he was out in the open before
no one shot him for no reason
well I got shot what do you guys think
I have nothing else to say free our
people then we'll talk
I came here to negotiate isn't that what
you want
[ __ ] what should I do I gave you my
answer what a plate like that okay
cool I made the wrong decision again
[Music]
the humans are about to launch an attack
and we will show them
and we are not afraid
if we must die today then we will die
free
[Music]
jeez your friend's life is in your hands
now it's time to decide what matters
most him or the revolution don't listen
to him everything this [ __ ] says is a
lie that human means nothing to me
hey hey you can kill him if you want I
don't care I have access to your memory
I know you've developed some kind of
attachment to him are you really ready
to let him Connor versus Connor all
you've been through are you really going
to turn your back on who you've become
I used to be just like you I thought
nothing mattered except the mission but
then one day I understood very moving
Connor yeah but I'm not a deviant I'm a
machine designed to accomplish a task
and that's exactly what I am going to do
enough talk it's time to decide who you
really are are you gonna save your
partner's life or are you going to
sacrifice him alright alright you win
I totally made the round what are you
talking about
it's pretty cool about it hold it it's
me Hank thanks hey I would have managed
without you get rid of him we have no
time to lose
it's me Hank the client want to use my
partner yeah there's a sec is [ __ ] well
Ashton is who's who that one oh they
both got shot
what are you doing Hank I'm the real
Conor give me the gun and I'll go to
move what do you ask you something
something only the real Connor would
know yes where did we first meet
Jimmy's Bar I checked for other bars
before I found you we went to the scene
of a homicide the victim's name was
Carlos Ortiz he uploaded my memory
what's my dog's name some sumo
his name is sumo I knew that too hey he
[Music]
my son what's his name
oh yes
Cole his name was Cole and he just
turned 6 at the time of the accident it
wasn't your fault
lieutenant a truck skidded on a sheet of
ice and your car rolled over Cole needed
emergency surgery but no human was
available to do it so an Android had to
take care of him Cole didn't make it
that's why you hate Androids you think
one of us is responsible for your son's
death Cole died because a human surgeon
was too high on red ice to operate he
was the one who took my son from me in
this world were the only way people can
find comfort is with a fistful of powder
I knew about your son too
I would have said exactly the same thing
don't listen to him Hank I'm the one who
god I've learned a lot since I met you
Connor maybe there's something to this
maybe you really are alive best buddies
best buddies go ahead and do what you
got to do
[Music]
wake up
Thunder Bitteroot wake up wake up wake
up wake up wake up wake up wake up wake
up wake up wake up wake up
wake up
you're it now you're it no you're it no
you're it
no you're right oh wow okay that's a lot
of androids that's a lot of damage
I feel like
she said
get forward when you hear this thing
that you got it I don't want to tell you
a second time
come on let's go vote
what's behind these doors they're
zealots
Alice Karl no Alice don't move that I'm
scared
I know you're scared Karlie's but you
have to trust me stay where you are okay
whatever happens don't move
they just went
and I can help you car
I can attract its attention
no Jerry
back your line cherry
and everyone knocking on I said
I was so scared are you alright
come on move it
dan
[Music]
escape
I can attract the guards attention
Luther
I will let them destroy any people I
love no listen you can't sacrifice
yourself we'll find another way there's
no other way
Oh
what can I do
[Music]
Oh
oh it's those Android
[Music]
I said cut it out
great you're going to have to get onto
one of those tricks
we won't be able to come with you what
what do you mean you can't it's too late
do I have to go now do you understand
I love you too
[Music]
over there
we're interviews at least now you the
latest news live from Detroit just yes
Michael the Army has just launched an
attack on the barricade despite the fact
that the deviants were protesting
peacefully have apparently decided to
put an end to the deviants demonstration
by force this time
[Music]
you're
come on marques
[Music]
she said oh my god the moves on this
look at the moves signs
ah
[Music]
we are alive we are alive and we want to
be free
[Music]
at dawn today November 11th
20:38 thousands of androids invaded the
city of Detroit according to our sources
they originated from cyber life
warehouses believed to have been
infiltrated by deviants given their
overwhelming numbers and the risk of
civilian casualties I have ordered the
army to retreat the evacuation of the
city is underway at this very moment in
the coming hours I will address the
Senate to determine our response to this
unprecedented situation I know that I'm
president right moved by the deviance
caused perhaps the time has come for us
to consider the possibility that
androids
are a new form of intelligent life one
thing is certain the events in Detroit
have changed the world forever may God
bless you and may God bless the United
States of America the humans are
abandoning the camp we won
you should oh my God look at him what is
wrong with him what is wrong with him
look at him oh my god everyone from
Jericho is dead you're the one who
awakened us Connor he's an early version
Android
[Music]
and dare you to on
hmm
[Music]
oh we're back she's well done Connor
everything went according to plan
what my plan you becoming DVD the
success of the uprising it all surpassed
our expectations we engineered an
Android revolution and now we control
its only leader congratulations you
represent an immense success for cyber
life
what are you doing
it all works perfectly oh my god can't
ruin it all now
no sorry Connor but we can't let you do
that
space odyssey reference
all right
all I ain't that way
what should we learn is there hint or
anything
there's some blue light over there we
should check that out
we'll do great things together oh you
kidding me so I didn't find it
[Music]
I liked all the ending so far except
that
[Music]
so we got bad ending with Connor
somewhat decent ending with Alice and
Tucker and then bad ending with Marquez
or it could be it could have been good
ending
[Music]
what a great game I really like that
I want to go back though I want to see
if I can get the ending with Connor okay
I'm replaying this mission because I
want to see what happens if they
actually escape you know what I mean
I'll really glad I got to see the ending
that I got but I I'm genuinely like I do
want to see them win as well as a family
and I just missed up this thing and the
whole game changed you really I'm super
impressed by this game the fact that I
really seem to have managed to make a
game where the choices do matter
incredible
honestly it wasn't even that hard I
don't know
well let's keep playing this route I
hope you guys don't mind literally a
check we have passports it should be
okay but you never know maybe we should
take the detour and avoid the risk we're
almost out of time we could miss the bus
yeah but you might be safer
all right let's do the checkpoint
what's the other what's the other idea
what's the other route detour 11 minutes
mister D dieter
oh we actually don't have time for the
detour
so we have to I'm confused
whatever we'll see what happens I don't
like humans who carry guns
they make me nervous just stay calm all
right Luther don't do anything until I
say something
ID please
[Music]
they don't realize there's Akopian
civilians aren't allowed out of ice
absolutely necessary we're heading back
where are you going our car just broke
down we're finishing on foot we live
nearby suspect something stay home
everything is fine go all right little
girl she's trembling coming wrong she's
cold
we really have to get her home fast
sorry miss but we got to be careful
there are deviants around and now guys
are nervous you should already on home
gets shot in the back hey wait a minute
he knows Kara they're gonna kill us
don't do anything Luthor you hear me
they're gonna shoot they're gonna kill
Alice
you dropped this
hey Alice you do go Bunga pinkie hey hey
all right we managed to his game the
risky round risky Road take me home
we're coming to you lot
unfortunately ash where thousands of
androids are marching to the city at
this variant skip this Val this have to
be later if the TV it's the one they
call mark the bus terminal we've arrived
Alice we made it alright here we are the
Canada border she what can we do then
stuck here now what are we going to do
fine tickets easy
I throw all of your likes you
don't move
you see yours yes she's adorable that's
it
got the sandwiches and I called your mom
let's get going before it miss our bus
you got the tickets right yes honey in
my bag Oh
[Music]
well
talk about it do you think machina all
right why Ellis you kind of lost them
did you have a good looking you burned
my backpack but he amble up must have
fallen [ __ ]
excuse me you didn't happen to see a
blue envelope somewhere did you
it has our bus tickets in it and never
mind
no sorry I know I set out a lie but it's
a video game here we have to find a safe
place for all over I'm so sorry I don't
know what happened they were right here
in my back I just want to see them
escape that's it dr. cricket yes here
they are okay go ahead Hey they're
humans they're gonna be fine okay
they'll have a bad day
stupid privileged humans and all right
let's go to Canada guys that's your ass
yes
he had to make a choice Alice
was them or us
they're not gonna die what the hell
[Music]
I don't know man yeah I don't feel bad I
really don't like the game is trying to
make me empathize with these people but
they're like if there was our other
Androids then I could kind of get it all
right so that's how it looks like when
he escaped now I want to try with Marcus
is if we negotiate and see what happens
hopefully we don't get shut down and
hopefully it's not just the same outcome
in a few minutes
trips have you ordered to charge none of
you will survive it'll all be over you
can avoid that Marcus
what do you mean
surrender surrender and I give you my
word your life will be spared you'll be
detained but 90 you will be destroyed
what happened to the other androids
demonstrating in the camps unfortunately
there were no journalists around to help
save them you're it you're the last
remaining deviants
I'm not afraid to die if I have to give
my life for what I believe in and I
won't have lived in vain that Android
you seem to really care about her didn't
want her to die
do you you know you could both be free
you could forget about all this you
could start a new life someplace else
just the two of you her life's in your
hands Marcus just say the word and
she'll be spared
you asking me to betray my people I am
offering you the chance to save your
people you're not walking out of here
Marcus the only thing you can save now
are the lies are those around you
I guess we'll have to accept it just for
the sake of story going differently
although I don't think personally I
would have chosen it anyway alright I
accept you made the right decision
okay we're at the border now
every everyone is fine Canada please
oh no inspection
[Music]
excuse me what's going on order control
all passengers must leave the bus
[Music]
this way please
we're doing temperature checks we're
trapped what are we gonna do
damnit so they get trapped anyway
I can't get to camera that I think of
something there's got to be a way out of
this
we can't let them stop us that it was so
close all the matters now is you and
Alice
I can save you Kara if there's no other
way I'll do it
we got to loot their pants cross the
border look for help let's see if
there's anyone
[Music]
okay we can't I can't move
oh it's her she's like you know I'm
going to everyone is here
[Music]
so
Jerry
you risked your life to save his car how
would he get through then if you and the
little girl need those fine I'll be
there so this is actually very similar
layout to
wait for me
we rarely think you're going Anthony my
daughter eats go to the bathroom
that's how they treat you had the border
control in America anyway nothing's
changed
[Music]
I'm so glad you're safe
we saw the Jericho rate on TV I was
terrified I thought he might have been
killed
I think honey all right
they're checking for androids we won't
make it through you have to how you know
what they'll do if they catch you
[Music]
rose
if anything should happen I'll be there
Gaara
[Music]
you gave me your brother's address do
you think that I of course
he'd be delighted to have you we're
going there too you'll be safe with him
[Music]
you're leaving Detroit they're searching
for the androids dota 2 where we had to
leave before someone turned to thin what
about the others they're crossing the
river as we speak
Adam and I are gonna meet them on the
other side oh cool so we get her just
across the river what's happening with
Marcus he's protesting peacefully
outside one of the Android camps
whatever happens now he's already made
the history books
[Music]
so how are we gonna get through exactly
I'm not trying to touch that are there
any other options the Jerry's
guess didn't Mita wouldn't need a
private place to talk to Gerry I
couldn't understand why my mother wanted
to help you guys seeing what Marcus is
doing made me realize she was right
so Marcus is changing people life you
deserve to be free
I just hope people realize that one day
I mean they don't even have fingerprints
okay here we go
well Jerry by
next please
i D
is she all right
[Music]
no need to be scared anymore there are
no a droids on this side of the border
[Music]
welcome to Canada
Thank You Jerry
[Music]
it seems to be all over here in Detroit
after negotiations with the Android
known as Marcus the androids have
surrendered peacefully and military
vehicles have been sent to collect them
the insurrection re-ask oh this is
different too
yeah no one liked that everyone dislike
that noise
why did you do that yeah we lost
sacrificing ourselves wouldn't achieve
anything we always said our cause was
more important than our lives our people
died here because they believed in you
our place was by their side
hmm I don't like this ending actually I
like the ending with Marcus sacrifice
himself it was pretty badass I just
wanted to see if there was a better
outcome but I honestly think this is
definitely it I did what you asked
you know the problem with you Androids
you believe everything there you go
hey screw this ending you don't think I
was gonna let you live after everything
that happened
I have borders you know
No No
causes lost your Android friends will
soon be destroyed
my girlfriend's been shot since you
seriously [ __ ] up Marcus clean up this
mess
des 4c don't okay so they die regardless
but they die for a better cause we can't
let you do that
all right come on Connor
I think I literally just needed to go to
that blue machine thing but I was
walking on the ice so he wouldn't walk
forward a hit
[Music]
walk on water
Jesus Christ
there we go
it's so wobbly it's making me sick
there it is how did I not notice this
all the other times maybe it was there
and I actually just legitimately know
Carter come on
come on
yes oh my god no Connor no no no no oh
my god no are you kidding way
well I got the darkest endings of all of
them great good job me
[Music]
all right was that the ending yep okay
so there you you boys and girls and
whatever have it that was Detroit become
human I think actually this is my
favorite one so far well done everyone
on Quantic Dream that seemed really
impressive I really felt like the
choices really mattered this time and
the outcome really mattered and it was
an interesting story and an interesting
concept I know there was like a mean
that I was forced to play this game but
I did genuinely enjoy it and I hope you
guys had fun coming along I'm also
really glad I made it my playthrough
because I know a lot of people wanted me
to play a certain way they wanted me to
make other decisions but I know I can't
please everyone so I figured I might as
well make the decision that makes sense
to me and I like the endings that I got
and we replayed some of them so I don't
know hopefully people are satisfied I
don't know but I just want to say thank
you so much everyone who supported this
playthrough who enjoyed it have fun with
it sharing your thoughts and comments it
was really fun following all that it's a
brought me back to the simple simpler
times I hope I will do more lights place
and something I always really enjoy from
time to time but for now that's it thank
you guys and goodbye